well welcome to the desk talk we're
running a little bit late my name is Jim
Crist I work for a continuum analytics
so we're going first actually how many
of you have heard of desk or heard
something about desk okay a lot of
people call call well that's excellent
so we'll start with a motivating example
just to get things going
um actually we'll start with this this
is the link to the materials if you want
to look at them later there are some
examples I'm going to run through that
not in full but they're up online on
notebooks so you can pull them down from
github later alright so motivating
example I have some ocean temperature
data it's a daily mean ocean temperature
data taken in a grid 720 by a 1440 array
every single day and this goes back for
years this is all provided from that URL
right there
so using Python it's really really easy
to analyze a single year's worth you can
it open up with a netcdf 4 which is just
the data format library and then use
matplotlib and numpy to run a little bit
of analysis and mega plots and that all
happens pretty quickly on your computer
it's just a few lines of code very
simple to work with so here we're
averaging the 1 years of worth of data
to get the amino efficient temperature
data for that entire year but what
happens if I have more so this is 36
years worth of data each one stored in a
yearly file it's about 15 gigabytes on
disk but that's compressed and so if you
were to decompress it you actually end
up with about 51 gigabytes uncompressed
and that is a lot bigger than the RAM on
my laptop I can't easily work on that on
my laptop so are we stuck
I can't load it into numpy do I have to
move to spark some distributed something
rather well not quite so we can use
blocked algorithms which is what I'm
going to be talking about mostly today
so what is it blocked algorithm well
here is an example this is the blocked
mean so let's say you have a data set
stored in an hdf5 file it's a trillion
element array it's on disk whatever and
you want to actually take the mean of
that well you don't have to read all
trillion elements and at once you can
actually do it in an iterative approach
so you can split up into 1 million 1
million size chunks
and then each chunk you can sum it all
together so you get the sum of each
chunk and then you can count how many
elements are in each chunk which in this
case is always going to be a million but
you can think of other cases where it
wouldn't be and then at the very very
end
oh so each chunk then you store so we'll
store all the sums of each block and
we'll store all the counts of each block
and at the very end we're going to sum
all the sums together we're going to sum
all the counts together and we'll divide
and so this is kind of a map of some
operation across all the chunks and then
some kind of reduction at the end and so
if you look at this loop this iterative
you know one chunk two chunk three chunk
none of the operations depend on the
previous thing in the loop so Python
would run this all in series this would
all go through you know Chum one chunk
to chunk three but they don't need to
you could just put this up into parallel
and so that is what that would look like
so you have your original array you kind
of split it up you'd use some
operational across all of it and then
you reduce it back together and so using
this kind of approach this block Dogen
can approach you don't have to load the
array in the memory at once so you don't
have to use you know have that much
memory on your computer that much ram
and we can actually expose some kind of
parallelism so that's what block
diagrams get you they get you
parallelism you can do more than one
thing at once computers these days have
more than one core would be nice if we
could use all of them and they can lower
your RAM usage you can work on datasets
that are bigger than the RAM on your
computer that's what we'd call out of
core so a data that fits on disk but
doesn't quite fit into memory so black
problems allow for parallelism and lower
RAM usage the trick is figuring out how
to break computations into a blocked
fashion so for something like this it
was pretty simple I word we're summing
each chunk and we're counting each chunk
and then we're doing a final reduction
just a simple MapReduce pattern but
other things can become more complicated
and so this is where task comes in so
desk is a parallel computing framework
that leverages the excellent existing
Python ecosystem so we have numpy we
have pandas all of those work great we
don't want to rewrite those we just want
to kind of use them but somehow make
them parallel it uses black block dog
UM's and task scheduling which we'll
talk about a little bit more later and
it's written in pure Python so it's
really really easy to install
can install ball pip installable nothing
to compile on our end if you have numpy
everything should just work fine so at
the base of desk in the red right here
we have what we'd call the desk core so
it's all built on a simple graph
specification which we'll talk about in
a few minutes that just encodes how you
describe your parallelism and then on
top of that we have built some
schedulers to actually execute these
graphs in a parallel fashion so we have
ones that do it in threading we have
ones that do it in different processes
one is coming about that we'll do it
across multiple computers but it all
comes from the same specification and
then on top of that in the existing
Python ecosystem we built a few
collections so we have dasker ray which
uses numpy internally and it kind of
exposes an ende array like object but
you can do parallel algorithms on that
desk bag is kind of like a Python list
i'm except we don't enforce ordering see
there's no order to it in desk data
frame is kind of like a panda's data
frame so desc array as I said it's an
out of core parallel and dimensional
array library we support a lot of the
numpy interface so we support arithmetic
you can do addition multiplication those
kind of operations on arrays we support
common reductions mean max we actually
have a generalized moment calculation if
people want to do some stats slicing so
normal slicing you do we also support
fancy indexing both of these can be done
in a parallel fashion and we support
some linear algebra so tensor da normal
matrix multiplication QR SVD we recently
got SVD compressed which is kind of a
fun little randomized algorithm so
here's the here's the fun part of the
talk do a little demo here ok
so in so I'm importing the array library
is that big enough can people read that
good get enough a little bigger bigger
ok actually I think I can get this to go
away too
yes excellent so dasker a imported this
da it's the namespace if I was to do tab
completion on that it looks a lot like
things you'd normally see at numpy so we
have some you fogs like sign but the
main one that we're gonna be using is a
from array to create an array so to do
that I'm going to create an umpire array
of size thousand by a thousand so just a
square array just for an example then
creating a desk or idea dot from array
this takes in anything that supports in
dump ice tile indexing so this can be an
umpire a but this can also be something
like an HD f5 file things that you can
actually pull some chunk out it has to
have a shape and then asked to support
slicing so there's a lot of data stores
I'm just data stores that support the
same syntax since you can load those
into arrays from that form so we're
gonna pull that in from X and the other
thing we need is a chunks parameter and
so what this is gonna do is this queues
are going to say how we're gonna block
up all right so we're gonna store it in
multiple chunks which we can actually do
the parallel operations on so we're
gonna store it in 500 by 500 chunks so
it's gonna be four chunks making our
whole array and so that's made a desk
array it has to be made at creation time
so you can do whatever you want for it
doesn't have to even be even numbers but
it has to be done on creation so tab on
that you can see the kinds of operations
we support so let's start creating
things actually what first visualize
what's going on
so what you're seeing right here is the
graph showing how the calculation is
going to be done okay so what we have
right here this is showing how the array
is going to be computed in memory so we
have our original array the numpy array
and then all it's doing is pulling out
each chunk that's all the operations
we've encoded right now so let's take
some of the whole thing note that that
doesn't run we haven't actually done any
computation right now we are building up
a graph of the operations we're going to
do and you can actually visualize what
that graph looks like at each step just
by tagging on the visualize method so
here we've pulled out each chunk and
we're gonna send me junk in and I'm
going to take a sum at the end and so we
can keep changing these together
let's do meaning across an axis and then
sum the whole thing together
you can keep changing these all together
I will do matrix multiplication across
this transpose and then do the same
thing see you getting more and more
complicated and so at some point these
are getting more complicated than you
want to write by hand but we've already
encoded these block Dugger thumbs into
desc you don't have to build the graphs
yourself and then at the end if you
actually want to run this you just call
compete on it and you get your answer
out and so this happened threads crawled
through that graph in parallel and
actually computed the result let's go
back cool so here we have a
visualization of how one of the task
scheduler is running through your graph
so this is a very parallel it's an
embarrassingly parallel operation and so
the scheduler is gonna crawl through and
it's dynamically scheduled so this is
all happening at run time and the
heuristic we use as we try to reduce the
amount of intermediates that are held in
memory so we don't to flood your memory
we want to make sure that we're pushing
things all the way through so we can
dump them and not use more RAM than we
need so in cases like this it works out
very well we're going all the way
through from start to finish for each
one
and then all those intermediates in blue
can be dumped and so we don't actually
have to keep them sometimes this breaks
down though so in this case at some
point here we're gonna get the entire
middle row all in red before it goes on
that is not a good use of the heuristic
actually this is old so the grass
doesn't do this anymore but it still
fails for some cases and so this
actually isn't bad though we contain
mechanisms to spill to disks so we won't
actually crash your computer and this is
happening so we try to minimize that I
mean it's try to reduce the amount of
RAM it using but in bad cases things can
still work question we can set the limit
of RAM being used for caching but not
for actually no we can we can using the
chest project I mean I can talk to you
about that later so as I said before
this is crawling through the threads so
some of you might have heard something
about the Gil the global interpreter
lock how many of you have heard that
phrase before crazy okay everyone has
heard about the Gil pretty much here for
those that haven't the global
interpreter lock means that a Python
interpreter can only execute one Python
instruction at a time so running Python
code in threads actually isn't really
running it in threads but in luck for pi
data it is oh so this is I like this
gift this is most Python programs it's
heavily using one CPU and none of the
others so anyway for pi data this
actually doesn't matter we're running a
lot of numeric C code or Fortran code
and so that all can release the
interpreter lock and actually run in
parallel so this is using tasks to do
what can actually be done in memory with
numb by a threaded operation of matrix
multiplication and then doing a sum
along a single axis and so what you see
below that this is a profile plot tasks
actually generates these we have nice
Diagnostics tools and so we have four
workers so each of those is a thread and
you can see the nice Gantt style chart
going through where they're all being
fully used and the plan and below is
showing my
CPU in my memory and almost immediately
we go up to using 40% CPU so I'm
actually using all four cores in a
single Python process using just threads
and that's kind of nice so in cases like
this for arrays this is actually faster
than using numpy but we've just done a
special stuff using a Python this is all
written in pure Python to make it work
so moving on so that original example I
had doing the ocean data we can actually
do that computation at all 51 gigabytes
of data using tasks
it's a few more lines of code we're
gonna create we're gonna open up all the
datasets using netcdf for that just
points to the file no data is loaded at
that time and then we're gonna
concatenate them all together using
tasks we're gonna create a bunch of
tasks arrays we'll call da concatenate
on them to get them all together into a
single task array we'll take the mean
across the whole thing at this
appointment can treat it as a single big
array and then the final bit we'll pass
it to a matplotlib so two things about
this one no computation has been done
until that final plot command - we
didn't actually call compute honored
askary ourselves so the task exposes the
array interface which is something that
numpy us and so functions that expected
numpy arrays and call an umpire as array
on their inputs if they're not which is
a lot of things in the PI the ecosystem
will automatically call compute so for
many array based things dropping in desk
works automatically which is kind of
nice so here's the plot this is all of
the data from 1981 to 2015 it's about 51
gigabytes this was all processed on my
laptop which does not have nearly that
much RAM and yeah just using desk so
moving on
oh I just put this in because I like
this graph this is the the graph from
SPD it's mildly complicated if this
isn't fast enough this is done in
parallel and out of course you can do it
on data that's bigger than your am if
that's not fast enough we have the
randomized one which was also put in and
so this is not this is not a 100%
accurate but it is it's an approximate
algorithm what I'm trying to program
ok so now moving on that's a different
so we had a desk array which copies the
numpy nd array interface desta to frame
it looks a lot like a panda's data frame
again we do a lot of the operations that
panda supports so we can do element
authorized operations we can add series
together we can do selections
aggregations group bys resampling
expanding window computations so a lot
of things that you might want to do for
working with time-series analytics are
exposed oh we have we have out-of-court
joins too which is kind of fun and you
can create dasker data frames from many
different sources so directory of CSVs
is a pretty common use
you just glob so the the star dot csv or
whatever your file pattern is you can
create a whole data frame from just
those and will encode the loading
operation and you can do computations
based on that any pandas object not any
series or a data frame for pandas works
castra is an experimental data store
that's just in there for completeness so
here's another example out of core data
frames I have yearly CSVs of All
American flights this is containing
information on the x airlines locations
it's about 121 million rows 11 gigabytes
of data on disk you can get it from that
URL there so I was able to again analyze
all of this on my laptop or actually do
a live demo on this one too
yes yes so I just CSV of how many rows
so that that's a difference between
arrays and data frames each chunk of a
data frame doesn't have to have the same
size which chunk of an array has to have
the same size if that makes sense
so I can load I've already converted
this into Castro just for speed reasons
you wouldn't have to do any conversion
this could be done directly from CSV s
but for a live demo this is a little bit
easier so we'll import sorry importing -
data frame is DD we'll create the data
frame so just loading it from castra and
this already looks like a panda's data
frame so some of these tab completion
are column names some of these are
methods we'll look at the clear so that
goes to the top look at the departure
delay so this is the delay from of
departure you can take the max of it so
let's see so this is the max of the max
delay for each column this is not
computed yet but we can compute on it to
actually get the result I'm gonna let
one run while I talk so we'll take the
departure delay we'll group by the
origin so where it took off from we'll
take the mean of that and then we'll
figure out the 10 largest so this is
taking trying to figure out the maximum
the top 10 mean departure delays by
airport over the entire time series so
all of the flights and this is gonna
take about 40 seconds to run if I
remember correctly but it's using a lot
more data than I can actually hold in my
memory but we're able to do this out of
core using desk so while this is running
it's about 12 gigabytes on disk so
actually actually that can fit on my
laptop but and we'll see in a second
here we didn't load nearly that much
data at a time quick question
is there something about disk I own that
I'm using yeah
that's hard to do in a cross-platform
way so for example that's not supported
on Mac as far as I can tell using psu to
anyway so this has gotten the results I
can take questions at the end I'm sorry
this is got the results up here this is
not the best example of data science if
you actually look up these airport codes
most of these are extremely tiny
airports in Alaska and they have about
one or two flights and they were all
delayed so so some kind of a
normalization would be needed but that
shows a it looks a lot like pandas code
except it runs out of core and in some
cases recently parallel pandas is more
and more releasing the interpreter lock
so match the presentation this is the
profile plot from that exact same
computation so you can see the blue line
there the dark blue line is CPU use and
so for parts of it we're getting more
than a hundred percent but for the most
part we're slightly above a hundred so
that's showing that most pandas isn't
nearly as paralyzing as the array stuff
and that's partly because of the
interpreter lock and that's partly
because the algorithms were using so
moving on the other collection I talked
about is desk bag well quickly I'm
running a little low on time we'll
quickly run through this it's an out of
core unordered list so think of things
that don't really fit the array
abstraction to really fit the data for a
map direction just some kind of
collection of objects so maybe a
collection of JSON blobs your log files
general string processing so there's an
example up on our blaze blog so about
reddit comments the addresses down in
the bottom corner there
this is pulled out of that so this is
using a desk bag to generate a word
cloud for all of the comments from our
machine learning so the machine learning
subreddit so we're pulling out the
subreddit and body fields of all the
JSON blobs we're filtering for just the
sub reddits that are in machine or the
comments there in machine learning
we're figuring out we're plucking out
the body field from each of those tuples
mapping a function to change the body
into a list of words or concatenate
those lists together and then we're
doing a frequency count and taking the
top 10 and so this will looks a little
bit like the spark API it's a lot like
most functional processing things it's
actually using a lot of the library
tools by Matthew rockin underneath and
if you actually plot that this was kind
of a happy thing that came out the top
two words in our machine learning are
more in data so this is this is using
Andres is a word cloud library so we've
talked about the collections on the left
here we have dasker a task bag and data
frame and imperative which I'll talk
about in a second here and each of those
creates a graph which expresses come
kind of computation we've encoded a lot
of parallel algorithms for common things
that you may want to do the graphs are
then passed on to a set of schedulers we
have a threaded schedule that we have a
multi processing scheduler recently we
have a decent distributed scheduler
let's talk about a second to the
intermediate representation is the graph
specification and so this kind of
decoupling is nice so what is a desk
graph so desk graph is a dictionary of
name and task so where the value is a
task tasks are tuples of function and
then some number of arguments it looks a
lot like Lisp which scares some people
but it so easy way it's a simple
specification arguments can be anything
that's hashable so each collection task
array is destitute frames has some kind
of metadata that we store in each of the
names in case of an array it's the index
of which chunk it is in an array so on
the left here we have some normal Python
code so setting a equals 1 B equals 2
we'll do some increment H and then
multiply the results together and on the
right we have the corresponding data
graph at the exact same operation and so
you can see they look fairly similar
enough it's just a slight rewriting so
death collections fit many problems but
they don't fit everything some things
can't easily be encoded in an array or
data frame or even the bag abstraction
and you might want to drop into the
graphs directly well the good thing is
that the schedulers are separated from
what builds the graph since you can use
the schedulers and this
directly so here is a sample workflow
you might have a loading function a
cleaning function something to do an
analysis of all the files together and
then something that stores and so you
can see the graph on the right there as
to what it actually looks like if you
were to do that and at the very bottom
are actually creating the graph so we're
creating a couple loading functions one
for each file we'll clean each file
we'll analyze all the files together and
then we'll store them and so that that's
nice and that's readable but it could be
a little more readable so we have
another collection that we haven't
talked about yet is des comparative
which uses a decorator it's a little
like Joplin if any of you have
experience with that and so you can
decorate functions or you can use that
in line two and this automatically
builds up a desk graph which can then be
run so you decorate functions with do
and then you can use them and there's
some limits to what works and I don't
have enough time to talk about that but
it's in the docs there's a fairly good
example of this and so we find this is a
pretty good way of working with things
that don't quite work with arrays or
data frames and so with that you can
create custom workflows so some recent
work has been done on using scikit-learn
with desk specifically the grid search
and the pipeline so on the right there
these are far too small to see what's
actually going on a little complicated
is the grid search and pipeline one and
on the bottom we have cross correlation
model and so both of these were created
just using des comparative and some
Python code and it's extremely readable
there's a blog up on the Matthew
Rockland's blog about it
so distributed I mentioned that earlier
it's been asked for it's a common thing
that people might want to do tasks was
started with a single machine thought so
thinking of a single large workstation
and this actual list is I love the title
of his paper nobody ever got fired for
using Hadoop on a cluster this came out
of a Microsoft Research a little bit ago
and it's got this nice quote in it for
workloads that are processing multi
gigabytes rather than terabyte plus
scale a big memory server may well
provide a better performance per dollar
than a cluster and we found that using
this trying to scale up rather than
scale out is a nice thing and it works
for all
a lot of common problems you don't
necessarily need to go distributed for a
50 gigabyte data set you can definitely
do that on a single machine but we have
been working on a distributed scheduler
it's up here this is the documentation
for it it lives outside of desk there
was one that was inside desk and that
got nuked in the latest release it's no
longer there it was a little bit buggy
this is a lot more robust mentioning the
place blog again there's a there's a
blog post up recently using the
distributed on HDFS alone with
absolutely no Java so pulling files from
HDFS and computing on them in Python
using a no Java code at all and that's
all done with distributed so takeaways
Python can still handle large data using
black dog rhythms you don't necessarily
need to scale up to a bigger machine you
can load a less in memory at a time data
collections form tasks graphs expressing
these algorithms schedulers execute
these graphs in parallel and - craftsmen
can be created directly for custom
pipelines you don't need to use the
collections you can create graphs
externally for further information
you've got a pile links up here so we
have our Doc's we have examples up in a
separate repo some of them are actually
active with binder so you could just go
online and try them out on binder
yourself it's a great service really
we're really enjoying using it blaze
blog right there we often blog about
projects in the blaze ecosystem tasks is
one of them we have a chat app on getter
and in github for issues or if you'd
actually like to get involved we would
love to have you questions I think I
have a few minutes yes yes so there's a
few caveats to that but in most cases
yes you can get parallelism in a single
file we actually be split we pick a
random index into that file along
characters and then we seek to the next
new line and then we break there and so
we're able to split CSV files into a
couple different chunks if you have a
big one no not logical chunks you would
have to somehow take care of that
yourself
yes
yes yes and so because the I'm sorry the
question was can you use
multi-processing is there a multi
processing scheduler and yes there is
you can actually drop that in so the
scheduler interface is the same across
all of our schedulers and so it's a
setting you can set it globally you can
set it locally we have a context manager
or you can do it computation by
computation it's a key word to the
compute method and so that just drops in
and say you by default the data frame
uses threading array uses threading bag
uses multi processing and we find that
for most things that works out ok and
pandas is more and more recently
releasing the gills so value counts
actually is an extremely fast
computation we can get pretty good
parallelism on that yes yes recently the
just uh just to clarify the distributed
scheduler is extremely alpha right now
so do not depend on it but if you want
to try it out we would love comments and
feedback on it which part are you
talking about using the collections are
you talking about in so the collections
build them up and so we're working
internally inside these array like or
data frame like objects building up a
dictionary expressing the graph yes yes
any other questions
I yes so I so personally I really enjoy
working with larger days that's on my
laptop so again that ocean desk that was
really fun to play with and I was doing
that all on my laptop which is about 16
gigabytes of RAM and so that you know 50
is a lot bigger than that
that's the Stephan Hoyer at climate core
uses desk daily as part of its library
x-ray and so he's using that for
processing up to the terabyte or two of
data a big array like things and he's
getting good use out of that so I'd say
for a race we can get faster than numpy
on a large enough size I think that
probably is computer dependent what that
size is so you can actually get
parallelism and that's a good thing
but you can also get out of core for
data frames the benefit right now is
mostly just the out of cornice you can
work on a larger data frame like things
that are bigger than your memory and
we're primarily targeted at the single
workstation single large machine a
problem I'm slowly branching out into
potential distributed use cases
yes see so if I understand your question
the graph is built up off the data and
so if your data changes if you have want
to run it on a bigger array per se you
have to rebuild the graph but the
building of the graph is pretty cheap it
doesn't take much time at all and so for
problems that's the other bit is the
scheduler has some overhead so the
scheduler has about a millisecond or so
per task max overhead and then you also
have the time to build the graph and
start up a thread pool or a process pool
so there is some overhead on running
those things but each task should be a
lot larger than the overhead for that
and so we find that the building of the
graph and the running of the scheduler
is very very very very small compared to
the actual tasks does that answer your
question
or okay I think we're out of time now
actually so thank you